In this case there are multiple, correct answers. So you should have
marked several of those. So let's go through the list. Well this
is definitely not true. They are used for something. The second answer,
is a correct one, because you can order, the use cases that
you planned to realize, according to
your prioritization criteria. So basically what
you're doing you're prioritizing either in terms of functionality. So you, you
can decide which piece of functionality you want to realize first in
your system. Or you can also prioritize based on the actors involved.
Maybe there are some actors, maybe there are some user
roles that you want to support before others, and we'll
see some examples of that. The next correct question is
that they can be used for requirements elicitation. Why? Well
because used cases express what the system is supposed to
do for each user. They're an ideal way to collect,
represent, and check functional requirements. And we'll also get back
to this. And finally, use cases can definitely be used
for test case design. So why is that? Because each
use case represents a scenario of interaction between users and the
system. So testers can very naturally construct test cases based
on use cases. And in addition, and most importantly, they can
do that even in the absence of code that realizes
a use case. So they can do it as soon as
they have the requirements. They don't have to wait until the
code is ready. So this is not very a important point.
So you can have your test cases ready even before
writing the code. And now for completeness. Even though this is
not listed in the quiz. I also want to mention two
additional uses for use cases. The first one is that use
cases can be used to estimate effort as we will discuss
in more detail in mini course four, when we talk about
agile software development. And they can also be used by
customers to assess requirements. Which
is another fundamentally important role of
the use cases. They provide a common language between the customers
and the developers which makes it easier to collect the right requirements.